hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and today we have a review of
the second episode of dr. stone king of
the stone world and this episode really
does continue the strong set up of last
week's premiere maintaining pretty much
every facet that I praised during that
review especially the world the
backgrounds in this episode was so
beautifully detailed and they really
sell me on feeling immersed into this
stone world although in terms of general
aesthetics I think the quality may have
slipped ever so slightly in terms of
character art there were a couple of
points in the episode where all three of
our focused on characters being sane
Kutai drew and Tsukasa felt just that
teeny tiny bit off model like went ages
forehead just seems to elongate all of a
sudden and it's in these moments where
it becomes quite obvious that the anime
has decided to take a bit of a departure
from the manga in terms of how it
chooses to showcase its various shots
which is to be expected I mean you can't
copy the manga panel for panel because
anime is an entirely different medium
but there are little chinks in the armor
like this as a result of not having boy
cheese art to reference directly but on
the other hand for the large majority of
the episode the characters were still
phenomenally drawn and you know what I
suppose we should talk a bit about our
newcomer to the series mr. su casa now I
was very excited and apprehensive about
seeing Tsukasa in action for the first
time because as we can tell by the end
of the episode his presence in the story
is very essential to act as a counter
philosophy to sanku so it was very
important to get him right and the good
news is I think the anime has absolutely
nailed him his vocal performance is
great with his voice actor doing a
wonderful job of simultaneously making
Tsukasa sound like quite a reasonable
human being while still being able to
carry that threatening atmosphere about
him which only really becomes apparently
to run in the episode when Cink who
draws our attention to it before that
point tsukasa's performance just fit in
so perfectly without group of pioneers
that it made me really wish that he
would just stay cool and even though I
knew it was coming being a filthy manga
reader and all I found myself really
wanting him to jump on board with the
group although I do have one slight
criticism about Tsukasa and it said I
was a bit disappointed by his animation
in action in the manga Tsukasa is drawn
as this incredible force when he's doing
something like punching a lion or
hunting you can feel the impact of his
raw power leap off the page and smack
you in the face
whereas I didn't quite get that with the
anime and actually as they extended his
whole hunting sequence it very much
struck me as to why that was and for the
most part it's because whenever he
performed in action it would be dealt
with in a static shot for example with
the lion you see him stop throw a punch
then we cut to the result which is a
static shot almost as if we just cut to
the exact page in the manga but with
this impact because it doesn't have the
full force of buoyancy behind it I mean
with all of that sad action isn't
supposed to be the selling point of
doctor stone so I don't really care too
much about not having it be flawless so
long as they nailed the important
character and science stuff and speaking
of what I think this episode did very
effectively would sue castle was convey
his motives in a very relatable and
almost almost reasonable argument in the
marker I found his character change a
bit sudden and mana Loki but in this
episode his flashback was very well
handled with great shots and use of
colour so it made me feel for Tsukasa
which in turn made his ideology much
more appealing to begin with like when
we go to the point where he was rambling
about if we bring everyone back to life
then they'll stop reclaiming the land
charging rent taxes etc I was actually
like look the dude has a point the world
was pretty [ __ ] as it was and it's the
more senior people in power who were
propagating that however then of course
Tsukasa loses me with the whole
purifying Humanity thing and his clear
discrimination against absolutely
everybody above a certain age but still
the anime handled this scene wonderfully
and not just in regards to Tsukasa
either but also sanku in this episode I
think san'ko's deeper character really
got its first chance to shine and one of
those moments was rejecting tsukasa's
ideals and allowing the audience in on
his own personal ambitions which show an
incredible sense of morality for someone
of his intellect in anime I really can't
begin to explain just how refreshing it
is to see someone so smart have such an
idealistic vision of the world because
generally smart characters are in tune
with the world and have become
accustomed to how it works and it'll
take some meat headed idealistic
brute-force protagonists to change their
minds but Senko is there right from the
get-go and I think that's why it becomes
so easy to get on board with him and put
your faith in the sky and during the
episode he also acknowledges that he
would be next to powerless alone and
that he needs the qualities that other
people like tide you can bring to the
rebirth of humanity and this is a theme
that will continue throughout the
entirety of doctor stone and is one of
the reasons why I really love cenk whose
character because as much of an absurd
genius as he is he isn't particularly
arrogant and he also possesses a large
degree of empathy for others who more
stereotypical geniuses would view as
strictly below them but sanku and tide
you pretty much feel like equals which I
really like and thinkers genius was also
highlighted this week in a wonderful
montage about the uses of calcium
carbonate and this was the confirmation
I was looking for to say whether or not
the core concept of this series was
going to be enhanced by the anime there
are an awful lot of points
page after page a scientific exposition
in the manga and I loved every second of
this montage being animated here I don't
think I've ever been so excited for
calcium carbonate in my life but here we
are the way it was portrayed on screen
felt like we were making progress our
first real discovery in regards to human
technological evolution and the sheer
amount of things that such a simple
substance allows them to do it confirmed
to me that the dr. Stearn anime is going
to work that I am going to thoroughly
enjoy this series and to add on to the
list of successes comedy did really well
this week too with my particular
favorite line being usually Hiro doesn't
have a dick and they're really really
like super squishy sounding I poke that
tide you delivered sanku not only that
but I'm also starting to pick up on and
enjoy the general soundtrack of the
series that's an awful lot to the
adventurous atmosphere of Stone Age
science especially the track right at
the beginning of the episode although in
terms of music I will say that after
having seen the ending for first time
I'm I'm not a huge fan of it the song
itself just does nothing for me it feels
frustratingly soft but kind of energetic
at the same time and I just wanted to
pick one either be a soft chilled ending
or an energetic bit of fun like the
opening plus all the shots of the real
world in whatever the hell kind of style
you call that just really put me off
although there is a nice montage of the
characters drawn by Buchi in there and
it is stunning stunning artwork so hey
this ending isn't all bad now I guess
all this left it's point out some
differences with the manga and the main
one this episode was that in the manga
the scene where Tsukasa saves the stone
girl from underneath the rock does not
exist the scene was entirely added to
the anime and I can see why in the short
term it contributes nicely to the idea
of Tsukasa being a good guy but it also
goes on to highlight his greater
philosophy of saving the pure-hearted
young folk and look without any spoilers
it may even go deeper than that so yes
it was a nice addition another thing I
found interesting is that when Cink who
was talking to tied you about Tsukasa he
posited that well what if Tsukasa turns
out to be an evil bureaucrat with
insatiable greed which could not be
further from the truth but in the manga
sync who said something very very
different and wondered what would happen
if Tsukasa turned out to be a sex-crazed
tyrant which mate I'd use little
imagination same with use a hero just a
little bit funnier but that pretty much
does it for episode 2 of doctor stone if
you enjoy this video and the content
this channel produced in general then
please do consider donating to the New
World review patreon because the support
of all the amazing people is what
continues to make this channel possible
and if patreon isn't quite your style
then please do leave this video a like
share
subscribe because it also helps what
this channels an incredible amount and
if you'd like to join the fun at anytime
then please do head over to my discord
server where a wide array of shenanigan
retakes place on a daily basis and
finally please do comment with your
thoughts in the episode this has been
the new world review and I'll see you
next time